und ich hoffe wirklich dass im laufe
dieses tages spätestens heute abend eine
gemeinsame harte reaktion des westens
auf dem tisch ist und zwar wirklich eine
die auch moskau blieben ist das ist
natürlich nur eine wirtschaftliche
reaktion über die wir sprechen kein
mensch kann es ist ein irrsinn ehrlich
gesagt das haben jetzt stehen die können
jemand einfach schießen können dass wir
hier stehen und darüber reden dass es
möglicherweise wieder krieg in europa
gibt und einen der womöglich dann nicht
mehr zu begrenzen ist ich bin gestern
abend mit dem gedanken ins bett gegangen
an die worte meiner mutter die
kriegsgeneration war und die immer
gesagt hat hoffentlich erlebt das nicht
mehr wir stehen an der schwelle dazu
es ist dramatisch emotional peter wir
schauen auf eine reaktion wir sind da
sich gestern abend auch auf sendung
gegangen meine